hello everyone
i am
knoxel
unfortunately sounds a little bit under
the weather today
i am kristen deserves the chief learning
officer at khan academy and i'm going to
attempt to fill a little bit of his
shoes today we are excited to have as
our homeroom guest psychologist new york
times uh best-selling author and uh
monthly columnist lisa da moore and
she'll be talking to us about the
emotional well-being of our students in
these coveted times so we're looking
forward to that
before we get started i want to remind
you that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization and we do
depend on donations to keep us all going
if you would like to donate you can go
to khan academy.org
donate and you know i know that this is
a tough time for folks but you know ten
dollars even uh helps contribute to
keeping all of these resources up and
going for folks that need it during this
time so thank you if you can do that
i also want to recognize uh some
corporate folks who have stepped up
particularly
in these covid times they've been
partners with us and really helped make
sure we can keep things running that
includes google.org
at t fastly bank of america and novartis
thank you to them for helping to
contribute to keep everyone learning uh
as we're as we're going through these
times
so with that
let me introduce
dr lisa del mar thanks for being with us
today
thanks for having me i'm delighted to be
here
excellent so
just this morning you i published a
column that speaks to teenagers with
your advice about how to navigate some
of this time we're living in can you
share with us some of the advice that
you have
sure so um in my september column for
the new york times i had written a or
actually was my august column i had
written a back-to-school well-being
checklist for parents with regard to
their adolescence mental health
and in the comments several teenagers
said um why don't you just write to us
about what we need to know about
ourselves and i thought as usual the
teenagers are right as usual they're
like totally on the money
so i um my editor who's wonderful was in
agreement that i could write this column
to them so this one is called dear
teenagers here's what you can do to
manage your own emotional well-being and
i talk through what we know in
psychology about how
adolescents in particular operate when
it comes to their feelings some of the
superpowers they have for example they
feel things more intensely
which we know
this means they feel difficult and
painful things more intensely it also
means they feel pleasures and joys more
intensely
and so at this time when we are all at
this point kind of limited to small
delights um that pumpkin spice latte
goes further for a 16 year old than it
does for a 30 year old and that's a good
thing that they can take advantage of
and i talked with about basic mental
health maintenance and what to do when
they're worried and how psychological
defenses work
but it was um i will say i've written
that column for five years i've written
for the times for seven i think this was
my favorite column i've ever gotten to
write
that is great and i
am sure that the teenagers appreciate
you talking to them because knowing
teenagers are thinking i can do this
myself i don't need the help of my
parents
to navigate all of this
um so thinking about parents though
uh what kinds of things should parents
be looking out for in terms of signs
that their kids might be struggling or
need some extra help
this is such a hard time and
the baseline we're starting from is one
of kids being pretty upset and pretty
distressed and rightly so
we are also starting from a baseline of
parents being pretty worn thin and
pretty tired and dealing with their own
stresses and anxieties
and i think in that context it can be
very hard to know when it's time to
worry is the kid overreacting is the
parent overreacting
so to start at the extremes and then to
walk it back
we worry when a kid's mood gets stuck in
a rut
so we fully expect the normal adolescent
mood will go up and down you know that
they'll be really salty one day and then
perfectly fine later that day or the
next day that's normal development
we worry if a young person becomes down
and stays down is sad lethargic unhappy
low for days at a time that's grounds
for concern or irritable
at every opportunity i take it to let
people know
that one of the forms that depression
can take in teenagers is irritability
it's sort of unique to adolescents and
sometimes it's easy to miss that they're
depressed because an irritable teenager
is you know we can just dismiss it as a
snarky teenager but any teenager who is
annoyed with their parents annoyed with
their teachers annoyed with their
coaches can't stand any of their peers
that is something that should be
considered a possibly depression
and we worry about anxiety that is
too big meaning out of proportion to
what's going on or
persistent even when things are okay or
okay enough so that's when to worry
worry and what i would want parents to
do is to reach out to a mental health
clinician or call their pediatrician
even just to check in and and sort of
you know get a take on things
um but then there's a lot
below that a lot that's less concerning
than that that's much more in the garden
variety
of day-to-day raising teenagers or
pandemic raising teenagers
can you tell us some of the the
strategies that parents who
of kids who haven't probably reached
that threshold yet but are just
struggling a little bit what are some
things that they can do
well a lot of it means just allowing
teenagers to vet
so one thing that is true about
teenagers is that they complain about
school
and they complained about all last
year's school year not just the school
year it's part of how teenagers do
school
and what i mean is they're wonderful at
school teenagers hold it together all
school day long put up with all sorts of
hassles and annoyances are charming
through the whole thing and part of how
they do it is they collect what i call
their emotional trash over the course of
the day and then they get home and they
dump it on their parents and this is a
normal and expectable transaction
works really well for the teenager
because they tend to feel greatly
relieved after this transaction is hard
on the parents because they can
sometimes feel burdened by it
but under normal conditions and then
pandemic conditions one thing that's
really helpful for parents to say when
kids are having a hard time or feeling
you know full of complaints
is to say
do you want my help with this or do you
just need to vet
and so often teenagers and tweens will
say i just need to vent
and then the parent can just let them
vent and know that they're serving
basically a functional trash disposal
service that lets
the kiddo move forward
the trick in the pandemic
is to try to measure how much more
they're complaining this year than last
year because they are
but what i think is important for
parents to do is to think okay on
september 29 2019 how much was my kid
complaining how far above that increment
are we
um the other thing i want parents to be
mindful of is that we're hearing more
complaints sometimes because we're
standing right there as school is
happening and so you know under normal
conditions your kid has annoying group
projects that happen during the school
day that you don't hear about because by
the time they get home they're either
over it or they've complained to their
friends
under pandemic condition conditions you
can run into your teenager in the
condition in the kitchen when they just
finished an annoying group project and
you're going to get the full download
so there's complaining there's
heightened complaining but i don't want
parents to take all of the complaining
as it's as though it's coming from a
zero start you know it's higher and
higher for both pandemic reasons and
also just um logistics of pandemics
that totally makes sense and your
comment about
asking do you need my help or not i
think applies to
you know emotional things but also i
know that learning itself is hard
and
kids can get in a place just in working
through what they're supposed to be
learning where they're struggling and in
in the educational psychology world we
talk about productive struggle and that
that can actually help people learn
but if parents are seeing that how
should they react to that and how do
they figure out when to help and when
not well for you to give parents the
gift of the idea of productive struggle
is such a good first step
because as parents we know our kids so
well
and if they're doing school like right
over there next to you you can sense
even if they're not saying anything you
can sense when they are starting to feel
tense or frustrated
and as a parent that makes
the parent uncomfortable i'm a parent
who has a kid doing school at home it
makes me uncomfortable
and so then of course we want to step in
and help help
um and
we think we're stepping in to help the
kid i will confess that i have sometimes
felt compelled to do it because it's
bothering me like i want to make it stop
so that i can focus on what i need to
focus on and my kids discomfort is a
distraction for me so i want to make a
stop not because i think my kiddo needs
it but because i sort of selfishly
wanted
so the first step is to recognize that
learning is grappling
and
that
kids getting frustrated and struggling
along is often when learning happens and
like you mentioned teachers know this
and teachers develop the capacity to
tolerate and in fact encourage
struggle in the classroom
and so that idea of taking the guidance
around emotional well-being and
transferring it over to academic
well-being to say you know give parents
a language to say something like
are you doing okay with that struggle
do you need any support around that
struggle but not even to try to get rid
of the struggle
but or mostly just to bite our tongues
until a kiddo maybe sends up a flag but
that's hard it's really easy to say hard
to do
yeah absolutely and i know it's it's
hard too if you're a parent who's trying
to work over here and
your kids on the computer over here and
you know when having them know when they
can ask questions and when it's okay you
know to to kind of jump in as opposed to
when you're in the middle of doing
homeroom session or whatever that may be
um i think it's another
piece that i've talked about can be
helpful for um for parents as well to
kind of give their kids a plan for what
to do when they need help um and so they
know what to do
excellent we are getting some
i've sometimes encouraged families under
normal conditions to actually have a
list of things kids can do when they
feel stuck because for me the big
challenges in school are getting started
and managing when stuck
and so it's really helpful to i've had
kids put a post-it note next to their
homework of all of the options for when
they get stuck move on to something else
you know ask the teacher for more
instruction phone a friend you know i
mean there's lots of things that kids
can do
and we can articulate those give kids
lots of options brainstorm options when
they're not doing their work so that the
first outlet isn't necessarily the
parent rescuing or the kid asking for
parent help
fantastic
so we are getting some good questions in
from uh facebook and youtube let me take
one of those from facebook rosa
bellinger asks
how do you get your kid motivated when
they're not turning in assignments
what's the best approach to handle that
okay so there's two pieces in there one
is motivation the other is not turning
in assignments those are two different
topics um let's start with the not
turning in assignments
um
i
think one of the real challenges in
parenting is to tolerate kids having to
sort it out with their teachers
and in my experience if parents don't
rescue kids and kids have to face the
music with their teachers and i trust
teachers by and large to handle this
really well and really effectively
usually kids don't continue to make that
mistake if they've had to really
have it out with a teacher and so if the
parent can't stand it they might email
the teacher and say i am well aware that
she's behind on her work i'm going to
leave it to you to figure out what you
think needs to be done here or to give
her the consequence that is coming
one thing when i have gotten to be with
groups of kids in person is i'll
sometimes have them
write notes of things they want me to
tell their parents so i visited schools
and i'm like what do you want your
parents to know
and i am blown away by how often i've
had young people write me a note saying
please tell them to just let me deal
with the consequences of my choices
don't try to intervene and so kids kids
can do that and benefit from that okay
then there's the motivation question
which for me right now in the pandemic
is like the million dollar question
um because motivation is low
and it's not the motivation is high all
the time under normal conditions it's
that it's lower now because kids are not
caught up in the current of school
they're not alongside their friends
doing work they might not really feel
like doing they're not being pushed
along by encouragement on person from
their teachers in the same ways they
might be used to
so the challenges of motivation that are
always present in education are now laid
i think more bare by the pandemic
and i think that it lets us have a
conversation that's probably long
overdue
about motivation in school
and the short on that conversation and
then kristen i'll let you ask me which
direction you want to go with this the
third on that
is that
i don't think we're really honest with
kids about the fact that a lot of really
high functioning students and high
functioning adults
sometimes need rewards to get work done
i think we've sort of made it seem like
you shouldn't need that or only
you know sort of the lesser students
require that kind of support
absolutely i
know for myself that sometimes when i
have to you know write a piece write an
article
i say okay if i write this page
i can have this hershey's kiss as a
reward so how do you think about
what are appropriate rewards and how can
we best use them to help kids succeed
well to let's take it zoom out and then
zoom back in so the language we tend to
use in education for rewards is
extrinsic motivation that you're doing
it because somebody's giving you
something it's a grade or money or
chocolate i'm right with you on the
chocolate for me it's coffee for me it
is um you know getting to take a lap
around the block walking you know that i
have a long list of rewards that i give
myself to do work um at times so we call
those extrinsic motivators and they're
in contrast to intrinsic motivators
which is basically the kid does it
because they love it like they just are
totally fascinated and drawn to the work
so we have generally and understandably
um
put intrinsic motivation on a pedestal
like that's the ideal that's what we're
working toward and i'm all for that idea
um i think all students so it should
come to all of their work open to the
idea that they might find it fascinating
i think all educators should do what
they can to present work in a way that
makes it as fascinating as possible to
as many students as possible so when you
have intrinsic motivation on your side
what you have is effortless attention
there's nothing to it and that's
fantastic
doesn't always happen so then you still
need a gear you can slip into to get it
done
that's the extrinsic motivation gear
there need not be any shame about having
to sometimes use that gear you use it i
use it we love our work we're doing our
favorite subject we're getting paid and
we still need that gear
and so the first step i think is to be
honest with kids to say that's okay that
you're not into the work still needs to
get done what's the play how are we
gonna do it
and i have been blown away by the
creativity students are sharing with me
about how they're getting work done
um students have been telling me about
youtube study videos that they pull up
where you can go on youtube and find
videos of very um studious and
you know thoughtful students it seems
working in libraries and they turn on
the video and they work alongside the
person in the video
i had a fabulous student tell me that
she makes time-lapse videos of herself
studying and she does it to keep her
self-focused because she wants to have a
good time lapse video so she'll work at
a 25 to 50 minute unit of work
uninterrupted so that she can have a
really funny time lapse video or a very
complete time lapse video to show her
parents or her friends and she said
they're very funny you know i love the
faces i make when i'm oh my gosh
really oh yeah so there's that there's
also chocolate there's also getting to
roll around on the floor with a dog
there's getting to take a lap around the
block with a parent
there is you know social media
right work really hard for 25 minutes
take five minutes to check everybody out
on whatever social media platform you
want
it doesn't matter to me so much what the
reward is i think it's great when kids
are creative i think it's great when we
make space for them to come up with
things we would have never thought of
what matters to me is we remove the
shame from it
that there is no reason to feel
embarrassed about the gimmicks or hacks
if you need them to get the work done
the work has to get done
that's fantastic and i i love
working with your kids to decide what
are what's rewarding to them so that
it's something that they value and is
important for them but yeah that's
fantastic i had heard of people doing um
zoom calls with each other and just
turning the video on to work
together
as as they're doing is a way to you know
just keep connected with each other so
all kinds of ideas
or it just feels lonely so another
option is for the parent to say do you
want me to come work alongside you you
know i can clear my email all day long i
can clear it next to you
um i when i was in graduate school i
mean i am i have great discipline and i
love my subject and i love what i do and
i am like the queen of hacks to get work
done and when i was in graduate school
my best friend and i used to sit across
a table from each other at a coffee shop
when we had 40 undergraduate papers to
grade and we played this game where we
could only speak to each other after
we'd each graded five papers and so we
would cloud five talk for ten plow
through five
we got done in probably four hours what
if i had been left to my own devices in
my apartment
would have taken me to a whole weekend
and
and those conversations that grown-ups
are not having with kids and that we owe
kids
and they're left with this sense of oh
the good students feel like doing it or
someday my motivation will show up i'm
stuck till then
that is not a helpful way to try to do
school
absolutely fantastic let's take another
question from facebook we have amaya
epleg
i'm going to kill this last name jihak
and again apologize for uh that last
name she asks uh i have a 13 year old
son that is screen obsessed i have
struggled to set healthy boundaries he's
seeing a psychologist but i would love
to hear your advice might be for setting
healthy screen time boundaries
okay so these are my rules and they are
pandemic
and also pre and post pandemic these are
my general rules for kids and screens
um first rule what really matters first
and foremost in my mind is what's on the
screen
what screens deliver is such a wide
range so school is fabulous good for
kids fantastic
educational tv
all for it um banal tv if kids need a
break and just a time to sort of relax
and rest happy socializing with their
friends kids need to socialize screens
are where that's at right now so there's
all sorts of good stuff that happens on
screens
i'm okay with hours of good stuff on
screens that's what a lot of kids are
doing these days i'm not okay with five
seconds of porn right or super violent
yucky stuff so
first and foremost what's on the screens
can't be yucky can't be something that
kids should not be seeing and and that
doesn't get articulated enough okay so
that's the first guardrail
the second guardrail is that screens
cannot get in the way of what is
necessary for healthy development in
children okay so here's my list this is
my short list we can add to this list
first and foremost sleep sleep sleep
sleep
elementary school kids need 11 hours a
night middle schoolers need 10 hours a
night high schoolers need 9 hours a
night
this is actually happening more than it
usually does because kids aren't
commuting or unfortunately doing after
school stuff
but sleep and screens are mortal enemies
i don't think screens should be in
bedrooms i totally get it that some
families don't have the space to do
otherwise i totally get it that some
kids are having to do school in their
bedrooms understand completely it should
come out at night so sleep
physical activity kids should be up and
moving around we have to work harder to
make that happen it's worth it
face-to-face interactions uh reading
people's faces picking up social cues
screens should not get in the way of
that
screens should not get in the way of
focused work kids should not have
screens interrupting their ability to
read with focus even do one thing on a
screen with focus sometimes kids are
doing like schoolwork and then popping
over to their phone to check their
social media not okay
and screens should not get in the way of
being helpful around the house around
the community all of the above
so my advice to parents is decide what
matters to you and then protect it from
screens
and before those things not against
screens and then the goal of course is
to have so much activity and so much
time helping out around the house and so
much excellent sleep that the time left
for screens is
minimized
but then the time on screens is spent
doing stuff that actually makes kids
lives better or gives them some
relaxation doesn't do any harm
that sounds very uh actionable and
useful thank you
i have another question coming in about
prioritization light in that way so from
facebook catherine terry says my son is
really struggling to engage with virtual
school and get his work done i know he's
emotionally exhausted as we all are i
feel like beating up on him about
academics is not as important as helping
him navigate and take care of his mental
health and would love to know your
thoughts
i agree completely
my mantra for the pandemic is this
the goal is actually not to see how
productive and disciplined everybody can
be
the goal is for all of us to get to the
other side of this emotionally intact
so
there may be moments where you feel like
i'm going to choose my kids well-being
over the perfection or even maybe the
completion of that assignment
i think that is a fair call right now
the other thing though
that's a good half step is to just go
ahead and empathize with him about how
hard the school piece is
i think sometimes when parents feel like
they can't fix it they feel like they're
helpless
you're not
there is a space between fixing and
doing nothing and that is the empathy
place where we just say
buddy i get it i you know i cannot
imagine how hard it must be to do school
this way this takes it's like school is
all vegetables no dessert this is no fun
i totally get it that will help your son
out the other thing that i think we
cannot overdo right now is just admiring
how well our kids are doing in spite of
what's being asked i think parents
should be saying constantly to their
kids you are doing a really good job
with this i see how hard you are trying
i am so impressed with how much
attention you're giving this given how
kind of dry or distant or disconnected
it feels
i see it i'm impressed way to go i mean
we that there is no limit on that right
now
yeah absolutely and when we talked about
motivation
we know that if you feel like you're
failing you're going to be even less
motivated to do something and if you
feel like you're having some success
even if it's small successes that gives
you more motivation to keep trying and
keep doing what you're doing so i think
that positive reinforcement helps
communicate that
all right i've got um
a another question that i know everyone
is is asking thinking about um how kids
are struggling because they're lacking
all the social interaction that they
usually have do you have any suggestions
about how we can
bring you know some of that experience
to kids how we can help them feel
connected to their peers
well
most kids a lot of kids are using social
media to stay connected um it's
interesting how quickly we've sort of
decided we're okay with social media
which i actually i i'm on that train um
kids should see their friends they
should get to socialize in person what
this means is that parents probably have
to supervise
and that's the challenge because parents
plates are already so full they're
trying to
run homes
do jobs outside the home sometimes and
also sort of monitor school
parents are down to their last minute
parents are spread very thin and the
idea of now having to
you know make
some sort of organized socializing
happen where an adult can be available
is just one more layer on top of that
and yet kids do need to see their
friends in person
what i would say to parents to make it
easier see if you can make a routine
have a standing play date with a kid
that your kid gets along with maybe
trade off supervision duties with that
parent but don't go week to week trying
to figure this out because that just
takes too much energy
but what i would say and this is
important and helpful for kids to hear
when psychologists say everybody needs
lots of social support which we do right
now
i think people often hear
everybody needs a big and busy social
life which is not what we mean
we actually mean something quite
specific in terms of social support and
this is true at all ages for kids and
parents
we mean everybody needs somebody to tell
their worries to
everybody needs somebody they can tell
their secrets to
and everybody needs a person or a group
who helps them to feel connected and
accepted
so some adults get this entirely from
their partner some kids get this from
one best friend
some kids are getting the worries piece
covered by telling their siblings the
secrets thing covered by telling their
friends they go to camp with out of
state and the connected and accepted
thing one good friend or they actually
really like their folks you know they
they've got those bases covered
so when i'm talking with kids about
their worries about their social lives
right now i like to run down that list
worries secrets connected and accepted
see if they are checking all of those
boxes if they're not that's something we
want to get on
if they are i then say to them that's
your cake that's what you really need
you've got those bases covered
everything else is icing
and
it's useful both in truly evaluating the
scale of the problem which is often
smaller than it looked
and also in terms of reassuring kids
that they're doing it right because of
course they're looking on social media
or they're aware it feels like everybody
else is hanging out all the time and
it's greatly reassuring to them to get
concrete guidance around what's really
necessary here
your guidance has been so helpful and
useful for folks that want to hear more
of this i know you have a book out in
2020 can you tell us a little bit about
that and what
folks can expect from that
so i have two new york times bestsellers
one published in 2016 and 1 2019.
the one from 2016 is untangled which is
about normal development in adolescent
girls though 80 of it applies to boys um
the one from 2019 is about
the epidemic of stress and anxiety in
girls which seems like way too timely
now again 80 percent of that applies to
boys
um but i also just launched a podcast
with my colleague reena nynon and it's
called ask lisa the psychology of
parenting it comes out every tuesday
morning it's 25 minutes long and every
week we take a question from a parent
you can also send questions to me if you
go to my website there's information
about how to send in questions
and we tackle whatever is top of mind
for parents right now because what we're
finding is the pandemic moves so quickly
the pressures on parents change so
um rapidly
that um once a week lets us really be
nimble in response to what is weighing
on parents and heart at home right now
that sounds great thank you so much for
offering all the support to parents as
we all try to get through this we really
appreciate your coming to join us today
uh so i will from here just close and
let folks know that if they want more
discussion about motivation topics
tomorrow we are have a webinar
uh that is happening at 4 00 pm pacific
and 7 eastern and there's a link there
that you can sign up for that and of
course
we will have a homeroom tomorrow
hopefully sal will have recovered and
can join us our guest tomorrow is
doctor
or superintendent austin buettner from
the los angeles unified school district
and so we'll be talking about some of
the challenges faced from the district
perspective
thank you all for joining us and have a
good day
you